[موسيقى]
اعتاد سائق شاحنه نقل خارجي على تعنيف
مساعده والتكبر عليه وبينما كان على سفر
عمل فوجئ بنفق اعتدى عبوره بامان فالشاحنه
بطول النفق الا قليلا لكن راسها اصطدم هذه
المره بسقف النفق فغضب السائق وراح يشتم
حظه ومساعده الذي لاحظ ما لم يلاحظه
السفيه وهو ان الزفت في الارض جديد ويبدو
انه سميك لدرجه جعلت الشاحنه ترتفع لتساوي
ارتفاع النفق
وماذا افدتني ايها المفكر العظيم رد
السائق مستهزئا فاجابه المساعد سافيدك كان
والدي يحذرنا من الغرور ويقول لنا ان
التكبر ينفخ الرؤوس فيصعب عليها التاقلم
مع محيطها نفسوها قليلا وحجبوها كي تصبح
سويه فدعنا نفرغ من عجلات شاحناتنا بعض
الهواء الذي ينفخها لتتنازل قليلا ونستطيع
العبور وهذا ما تم بنجاح فهل تحجم راس
السائق الى العناوين
دمشق تعود الى الحضن العربي
المتجمد من المحيط الى الخليج
الرئيس الايراني في دمشق اتفاقيات
اقتصاديه وزيارات دينيه
تنصيب كنسي مسيحي لملك بريطانيا لا ينفصل
فيه الدين عن السياسه
درس بيجال الالمانيه تكسر الهلال عشيه
انتخابات تركيا المفتوحه على كل
الاحتمالات
اعتراضات على حفله مدرسيه في الكويت
تكريما للطالبات المحجبات
هل منع مرافقون رئيس وزراء الهند اطفاله
فقراء كرنك من لمسه
السودان برغم معاركه الدمويه هل هو اكثر
امنا من الولايات المتحده
توتال الفرنسيه ترفع نسبه السرطان في
اليمن وتدمر الثروه الزراعيه
سكير يقتحم عاريا مسجدا في المغرب وطبيب
يتحول الى عامل تنظيفات في السعوديه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا
اختتمت تحقيق بماسى القرن في سوريا
وقيدت الدعوه ضد مجهول ورفعت الجلسه بدون
قراءه الفاتحه على ارواح الضحايا على ان
تستبدل اكادير الزهر بالتبرعات لخيام
النزوح الابدي
النظام السوري يعود الى كرسيه على طاوله
جامعه الدول العربيه
وذلك بعدما اتم واجباته نيابه عن انظمه
النفس الواحد شهيقا وزفيرا في افهام
الشعوب بان الحريه في مضارب العرب اربعه
حروف حاء الحرام وراء الروع وياء الياس
وتاء التدمير وان عدتم عادوا ومعهم نسور
الغرب ودببه الشرق
ومتيسر من ذئاب الاقليم وضباع الوطن
الحنون لتصبح تحيه الصباح تصبحون على وطن
[موسيقى]
الاسد الى الجامعه العربيه هكذا قرر العرب
رغم تحفظ البعض ورغم ان اسباب ابعاده ما
زالت موجوده لكنه عاد وحجز بذلك مقعده في
قمه الرياض بعد ايام قطر غردت خارج السرب
فموقفها من التطبيع مع النظام السوري لم
يتغير يؤكد المتحدث الرسمي باسم الخارجيه
في الدوحه لكن الا تخطئ الدوحه بعدم السير
في اعاده دمشق الى الحضن العربي الذي تشعر
بدفئه الان فلسطين التي تتابعون التغطيات
المباشره لاحداثها تحت ضربات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وتدليس المستوطنين الدائم
للقدس السودان ايضا يشعر بدفء الحضن
العربي وبحراره عاليه وكذلك اليمن والعراق
ولبنان وتونس وجيبوتي والصومال
اما الاداره الامريكيه التي ضمنت طيله
السنوات الماضيه عدم امتلاك المعارضه
السوريه صواريخ مضاده للطائرات فقد تمسكت
بموقفها المضاد للتطبيع مع دمشق ما يفسره
البعض بان امريكا لا تريد النظام السوري
وفي نفس الوقت لا تريد رحيله واوضح الوزير
بلينكن ان الولايات المتحده لن تطبع
علاقاتها مع نظام الاسد في موازاه عرس
دمشق الغيابي في الجامعه العربيه بالقاهره
كان الحاضر الابرز في دمشق الرئيس
الايراني الابراهيم رئيسي الذي قام بزياره
وصفها الاعلام في سوريا وفي ايران بانها
تاريخيه وقد اسست الاتفاقيات رسميه طويله
الامد فالاقتصاد واستراتيجيه محادثات توجت
بمذكره للتعاون الاستراتيجي الطويل
اتفاقيات في الزراعه والنفط والنقل
والاتصالات وعندما شنت الحرب ضد سوريا منذ
12 عاما لم تتردد ايران في الوقوف الى
جانب سوريا الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي
حرص على زياره المقامات الدينيه في دمشق
حيث ظهرت عليه علامات التاثر اثناء زياره
مقام السيده زينب كما زار مقام السيده
رقيه بعد زيارته مقام الحسين في المسجد
الاموي حيث اقيم مجلس عزاء حسيني
[موسيقى]
وامام الرئيس الايراني الضيف انشد نشيد
ترحيبي باللغتين العربيه والفارسيه نقل
اليه التحيات سوريا واليمن والعراق ولبنان
والقدس
[موسيقى]
من دمشقنا ننتقل الى لندن فما الابعاد
الدينيه لمراسم تتويج ملك بريطانيا
الثالث تسال هيئه الاذاعه البريطانيه
وتجيب ان القانون في بريطانيا يمنع تتويج
او توريث العرش لاي شخص من خارج المذهب
البروتستانتي المسيحي اهو اقصاء
للبريطانيين من مذاهب وديانات اخرى والغاء
للملحدين واللاتينيين حيث ان اكثر من سبعه
وثلاثين بالمئه لا يعتنقون اي ديانه تضيف
بي بي سي ان الملك في بريطانيا هو حارس
العقيده المسيحيه
البروتستانتيه بتكريس من باب الكنيسه
الكاثوليكيه ليو العاشر عام
1521 فهل هذه المسيحيه سياسيه لا ينفصل
فيها الدين الدوله وعن غزواتها السابقه
لسلب واخضاع محتلات لا تغيب عنها الشمس
يسال محلل ادهشه على صعيد اخر ظهور غريب
لاحد الاشخاص في حفل تتويج الملك تشارلز
اثار جدلا في الصحف البريطانيه وكتبت
الذيل ميل الممازحه لقد اكد جمهور العائله
المالكه انهم شاهدوا ملك الموت في كنيسه
وستمانستر خلال التتويج من ابرز لحظات
الحفل كانت لحظه تتويج الملاك عند وضع تاج
القديس ادوارد على راسه هذا التاج الذي
يتجاوز عمره 360 عاما
وهو اهم التيجان واقدسها على الاطلاق
ويستخدم فقط في لحظه التتويج سيحمل الملك
بيده كذلك صولجان الصليب في يده اليمنى
سيحمل كره ذهبيه هذه الكره التي يعلوها
صليب ترم الى العالم المسيحي من اقدم
جواهر التاج ملعقه التتويج وتستخدم لمسح
الملك بالزيت المقدس هذا المشهد الديني
العابر للقارات المؤصله للحكم بالرموز
الدينيه اعتاد عليه الاعلام الاوروبي
العلماني لكن بعضه لم يهضم بعد سوره
الهلال على علم تركيا فضمن حمله اعلاميه
غربيه تطالب برحيل الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان عشيه الانتخابات التي توصف بانها
مصيريه تنشر صحيفه ديرش بيجل الالمانيه
صوره لاردوغان وتكسر فوقه الهلال رمز
تركيا والاسلام بحسب المفاهيم التركيه
اسلام سنغسل
اغلفه الصحف الاوروبيه لن تؤثر بالاراده
الوطنيه للاتراك يقول اردوغان في رد على
مجله الايكونوميستال البريطانيه التي تصفه
بالطاغيه وقد ان اواني رحيله في المقابل
اليس للاعلام الغربي في هذا العالم
المفتوح ان يعطي رايه في الشان التركي كما
يبدل اتراك واخرون رايهم باليمين الاوروبي
مثلا
ما هي ماخذ الغرب على اردوغان يجيب المرشح
النيابي العلماني المعارض في تركيا حسن
جمال بان اردوغان قام بتحويل وجه تركيا من
الغرب الى الشرق ومن العلمانيه الى
الاسلام
هل يقتصر التدخل الغربي في الانتخابات
التركيه على اغلفه المجلات كشف وزير
الداخليه التركي سليمان
جرى بين الطاوله السداسيه للتحالف
المعارضه وبين سفير دوله اوروبيه لطرح
مسوده اتفاق عليها حيث يمتلك سولو تسجيلا
صوتيا عن ذلك يؤكد بان واسط قبل غيرها لا
تريد اردوغان مستشه بعضله لسان جو بايدن
حين اعلن سابقا وبكل صراحه بان دعم
المعارضه التركيه لاسقاط اردوغان هو بديله
عن الانقلاب العسكري للاطاحه
بهبل في عنوان
[موسيقى]
بلغ نهاياته قبل فتح صناديق اقتراع الرابع
عشر من ايار مايو امام ستين مليون تركي
للتجديد
او لتغيير المشهد في تركيا وفي المنطقه
المنافسه شرسه وعلى المنخار كما يقال في
مضمار سباق الخيل استطلاعات الرئيس تشير
الى تقارب بين اوغلو واردوغان وسط هذا
المشهد الاقليمي والدولي الذي يبرز فيه
تمسك دول وقادتها باصولهم الدينيه ضاق في
عين نشطات نسويات عربيات وشيء من اعلام
غربي نشاط مدرسي اسلامي في الكويت تم من
خلاله تكريم طالبات قررنا ارتداء الحجاب
الشرعي تحت ذريعه ان الحفل تقصي غير
المحجبات منيح اللي ما اقصوهم عن عرش
بريطانيا
للفتيات في السن بعدهم ما يقدرون يدركون
فيه ولا عندهم وعي يقدرون يميزون فيه بحيث
اني اعتقدون ان الحجاب شيء طبيعي الحين
بالمدارس الخاصه يسوون حفلات هالوين حفلات
كريسماس
او اطفال مسلمين ما يحتفلون معاهم ايش حق
ما قلتوا تمايز ايش حقه ما قلتوا حرام هذا
ايها الحاكم الفذ قبل ان تنفخ في الفتنه
الطائفيه لتمكن حكمك اعلم ان الطائفيه
ستتحول سريعا الى مذهبيه ثم الى اصغر من
ذلك او اكبر حتى تطرق باب بيتك بين الاخي
واخيه في ظل اجواء الشحن الطائفي التي
تفرضها جماعات هندوسيه متطرفه مواليه
لحكومه الهند
تفلتت الامور في ولايه مانيبور شمال شرقي
البلاد اثر اشتباكات عرقيه وقبليه سقط
فيها عشرات القتل فيما نزحت الاف العائلات
عن بيوتها بسبب ما تصفه بعض القبائل
بالسياسات الحكوميه القائمه على التمييز
وعدم المساواه في الحقوق السياسيه
والانمائيه وقد عزز الجيش حشودا عسكريه
لتطويق الاشتباكات في هذه الاثناء رئيس
الوزراء الهندي نارين درامودي وخلال جوله
انتخابيه بولايه كارنتاكا نجح بمساعده
مرافقيه بحسب الفيديو الذي اطلعنا عليه في
منع اطفال المناطق المهمشه الفقيره من
لمسه اثناء لقائه الاستعراضي بهم من خلف
اسلاك شائكه كما وصفت
تراجع
طباخيني بريكوجين قائد ميليشيات او الحرس
الثوري الروسي كما يحلو للبعض تسميتها عن
تهديده بالفرار من الزحف في منطقه بخموت
بشرق اوكرانيا بعدما تلقب وعودا بتقديم
موسكو مزيدا من الاسلحه والذخائر
لميليشياته وقد ظهر بريجوجين يلطم من بين
جثث بعض مقاتليه ويعنف او يشتم القياده
العسكريه الروسيه
بكل الاحوال رئيس الشيشان رمضان كاديروب
جاهز لملئ اي فراغ وينتظر اشاره من الرئيس
بوتين لاعلان الجهاد في باخمه الاوكرانيه
ارقام مخيفه عن اعداد ضحايا المجازر
المتنقله في الولايات المتحده اعيد
التذكير بها بعد مجزره بمركز تجاري في
ولايه تكساس نفذها من قتلته الشرطه دون
معرفه دوافعه وبما ان الجريمه لم تصنف
ارهابيه فاطمئنوا ليس فيها اسماء اسلاميه
بالطبع قتلى ومصابنا في احدث عمليه اطلاق
نار ضمن سلسله غير مسبوقه من عمليات القتل
الجماعي في الولايات المتحده استهدفت هذه
المره مركزا تجاريا مزدحما شماليه دالاس
بولايه تكساس وبحسب منظمه
فقد قتل خلال العام الماضي اكثر من
18,500 شخص في حوادث اطلاق نار جماعيه
بالولايات المتحده بينما رصدت
10300 حاله انتحار في العام نفسه ينصح
بهيز بعدم السفر الى الولايات المتحده
فالسودان اكثر امنا منها لانك تعرف هناك
اين الاشتباكات فتبتعد عنها اما في امريكا
فالمجازر تاتيك بدون تحديد الموعد والمكان
ثم لا تنسوا صحيح ان السودان يحصي ضحاياه
بصمت لكن برعايه كامله من الحضن العربي
الحنون تسببت المعارك منذ اندلاعها في
مقتل مئات الاشخاص واصابه الالاف وعرقله
امدادات المساعدات وفرار مئه الف لاجئ الى
خارج البلاد
[موسيقى]
صديقي المتابع في كل ما تصبو اليه لا تضع
محطه وصول وليبقى قطار كسائرا مدى الحياه
ما اخفقت في انجازه السنه الماضيه ستنجزه
ان شاء الله هذه السنه
وبكفاءه اعلى مثلا شاهدوا معي كيف انشد
مغني اماراتي للسنه الماضيه نشيد اسرائيل
الرسمي غناه بنشاز واضح خرج فيه عن المقام
الموسيقي وتنافر صوته مع الهرمونيا
الناظمه للحن
[موسيقى]
يجب ان لا نستسلم لاخطائنا المغني لم يئس
بل اشتغل على صوته طيله السنه ليؤدي ان
نشيد الاسرائيليه هذا الاسبوع مع مغنيه
عبريه باتقان موسيقي اعلى جعل المتحدث
باسم بن يمينه ياهو
بادائه المؤثر في احتفال سفاره تل ابيب
بابو ظبي بذكرى قيام دوله الاحتلال
[موسيقى]
شركه توتال واجهه فرنسا في مجال النفط
والطاقه متهمه في تحقيق صحفي فرنسي باغراق
بمنهج للاراضي الزراعيه والمياه الجوفيه
في اليمن بالاف الاطنان من المواد
الكيميائيه السامه ما ادى الى رفع نسبه
امراض السرطان بين المواطنين اليمنيين
فضلا عن تدبير الحياه الزراعيه
تحقيق الذي يحمل اسم المياه السوداء
لتوتال في اليمن يؤكد ان الاف الاطنان من
المواد الكيميائيه السامه التي القتها
توتال ادت الى تلوث الاراضي الزراعيه
والمياه الجوفيه كما تسببت في ارتفاع
معدلات الاصابه بداء السرطان في المنطقه
فرنسا التي تستهلك يوميا ملايين عبارات
حقوق الانسان والحيوان هل تستجيب لحملات
حقوقيه تطالب بمحاسبه شركه توتال وتعويض
الضحايا في الانفس والزراعه فيما تجري
حاليا حملات حقوقيه من قبل المجتمع المدني
اليمني والدولي تطالب بفتح هذا الملف
ومحاسبه المتورطين فيه وتعويض المتضررين
في المتفرقات العربيه وفي حادثه صادمه
بينما كان المصلون في مسجد بمدينه فاسا
المغربيه يستعدون لاداء فريضه صلاه الفجر
اقتحم شاب مخمور محراب المسجد
مجرد من معظم ملابسه قبل تمكن المصلين
ومعظمهم من المسنين من اخراجه الحادثه
اعادت احياء جدل كان قد اشعله وزير العدل
المغربي الغريب عبد اللطيف وهبي يتعلق
بالغاء ماده عقوبه السكر العلني من
القانون لان الماده براي الوزير تظلم
مواطنين لطيفين كيوت لا يؤذون احدا
متغافلا عن ملايين الضحايا حول العالم
تحصيهم الامم المتحده بنتيجه احداث وحوادث
مميته يفتعلها ويسببها السكاره
عمرنا غادي نعتبر
طبيب اسيوي يعمل عامل نظافه في مطعم
بالسعوديه اكتشف ذلك صاحب المطعم فاعلن
انه سيكرمه وسيساعده على استعاده مقعده في
مهنه الطب واظهر الفيديو مالك مطعمه
ويتحدث مع احد العاملين الوافدين قائلا
تخيلوا عندي في المطعم يشتغل طبيب الدكتور
محمد طبيب بشري وتابع اتى هنا ليعمل طبيب
ولكن صار لديه مشكله فاتى الينا ليعمل
بالمطعم ووجه موثق الفيديو الشكر للطبيب
قائلا شكرا لك يا دكتور لازم نرفعك ما
نخليك هنا تقديرا لك
قصه الختام يرويها لنا هذا الاسبوع طفل
غزه الشهيد علي عز الدين الذي لن تروي
حكايته مجامع الحقوق الدوليه
فنصيب علي انه لم يولد في اوكرانيا بل ولد
في غزه بفلسطين وفوق غزه منظومه صاروخيه
قاتله تكره الاطفال
وتخطفهم من بيوتهم ومدارسهم وملاعبهم
وترسلهم الى القبور
فهناك في مكاتب مظلمه في تل ابيب
دراكلا لا تعيش الا بسفك لا يتوقف للدماء
الى اللقاء انا الطالب علي عز الدين الدرس
الرابع
العصفوره والافعى
ذهبت عصفوره الى حمامه تقف على غسل شجره
وقالت لها يا صديقتي كلما فقص بيضي وكبرت
فراخي جاءت افعى كبيره
وصعدت على الشجره واكلت الفراخ والبيض
ففكري لي في طريقه اتخلص بها من هذه
الافعى
فكرت الحمامه وقالت اقيمي عشك فوق شجره
عاليه في احدى الحدائق العامه التي يزورها
الناس كثيرا
عندها تخاف الافعى من الناس ولا تاتي مره
اخرى وبذلك
تتخلصين من شرها
[موسيقى]